it's great to be joined today by thomas
frank author of listen liberal what's
the matter with Kansas as well as a
number of other books it's so great to
talk to you I've been following your
work for some time and one of the
elements of your recent writing your
recent book that I'm interested in is
sort of your critique of the Democratic
Party for really a number of reasons and
I don't want to put words in your mouth
so sort of let's start there when you
look at the 2016 Democratic Party
what are your critiques from a sort of
left progressive perspective well
I would actually go back I would make it
into I would say it's a historical
critique you know that goes back a
number of years but and by the way I
should have said at the start David it
is great to be here thank you so the it
but were the we're listen liberal really
starts is my with my disappointment with
the Obama years because like many people
I had very high hopes for Barack Obama I
thought he was entering the presidency
you know taking office at a you know
really critical historical moment for
our country I thought you know you
remember what it was like in 2008 and
2009 I thought that he was our
generations Franklin Roosevelt you know
I thought this was a this was exactly
the right man to deal with the horrible
situation that we were in at the time
you know with the basically the economy
no longer functioning and the financial
crisis and the beginning of the Great
Recession and what he did instead was he
basically continued the you know Bush
administration's policy towards Wall
Street at least for the critical first
couple of years and in his time in
office you know he's he's achieved a
number of things the main one being
Obamacare but in you look at his time in
office and inequality has grown worse
and worse in this country so it is true
that the economy has
recovered at least by all the formal
measurements right the Dow Jones
Industrial Average is I mean it all-time
highs the stock market is doing well
across the board as a matter of fact you
know things are the the economy is
growing not it's not doing great but at
least it's moving again but for average
people it's as though the recession
never ended we've got this kind of
curious situation that we're in now
where something fundamental has changed
about American life and Obama himself
has talked about it right he's the one
that says that inequality is the great
issue of our time Obama himself talks
about it very eloquently but he hasn't
been able to do anything about it or he
hasn't tried to do he's failed to do
what basically essentially what needed
to be done and that's the starting point
of the book I wonder why that is so
let's see if we can break down some of
these ideas into component parts I mean
I think there's no question whatsoever
that any self-described progressive
would look at the totality of the Obama
administration and say I can find
victories but I also find a by-and-large
continuation of the broader status quo
and this is sort of related to the the
narrow scope of what even counts as
valid debate in politics in the United
States is it slightly left of center or
is it to the right of the center but I
would couch it sort of in a different
way and I'm curious what your reaction
is and I know that in the book you
reject the idea that President Obama's
lack of more progressivism can be
attributed to Republican obstructionism
I know that that's not an idea you find
particularly valid or you or your
support but my question is this which is
given the pace and at which we know the
American government moves and get things
gets things done and given the reality
that Republican obstructionism or the
brought the broader huge American
apparatus of government that exists
can't we say that given what one
president could do in
years there's a fair number of
accomplishments that that even someone
like for example Ted Kennedy who had an
incrementalist approach would say we've
taken a lot of steps to the left well so
no I think that he could have done a lot
more and I think that the the country
would have been behind him and doing a
lot more the country was certainly
behind him in 2008
you remember those enormous rallies yeah
and this this was a guy who had the wind
at his back and he had majorities in
both houses of Congress and he had these
you know Chicago tough guys like rahm
emanuel with him who knew how the system
worked and knew how to twist arms and
you know and he came away with given
that he came away with quite little in
my view now so i don't downplay
republican obstructionism i wrote a
whole book about republican
obstructionism called the wrecking crew
a couple of years ago i mean this is
this is you know this is an important
fact of life in washington DC what's
fascinating to me is that when Barack
Obama came into office he pretended he
had never heard of this the you know the
problem of Republican obstructions like
this is a surprise to him you know he
when he reached out to people like Chuck
Grassley you know on Obama care and let
this guy basically sabotage the you know
the workings OB you remember this way
when I dragged on for weeks and weeks
and weeks while he waited for chuck
Grassley to sign off on some part of it
so that he could claim it was bipartisan
it's like he had missed all of the 1990s
you know that when Newt Gingrich made
obstructionism basically the philosophy
of the Republican Party and so that was
um you know I know that being bipartisan
is supposed to be the last word in
sophistication and pragmatism but this
struck me as as really naive you know
especially SiC given who you know that
Obama could easily have you know turn to
any of the people around him including
someone like Bill Clinton who knew about
this too firsthand and you know Bill
Clinton who's not a man that I admire
but but plenty of people and all I'm
saying is lots of people in Washington
know about Republican obstruction
it should not have been a surprise to
him coming into office in 2009 though he
should have mino' there there were all
sorts of ways to deal with it for one
thing he had majorities in both houses
with a simple sort of structural
adjustment in the Senate even the you
know the filibuster wouldn't matter
anymore something that I think by the
way is long overdue they should have
done away with the the power of you know
of a minority of senators to stop
legislation that should have been done a
long time ago Obama was a senator he
knew this you know that that he then
gave Republicans essentially handed them
veto power over his own program when he
didn't need to when there's no
structural reason to do it you know
that's his mistake that's not you know
that's not the Republicans per se we
know what they're gonna do right that we
always know they're always do the same
thing we know what they're gonna do
that's his mistake
that's his blunder and you know or is it
a blunder
that's what I started wondering after a
while I mean you you know when they when
you look at something like the way that
Obama dealt with the banks where it's
not you know the tarp was already passed
he had the power of of you know of the
US Treasury they just bailed out all the
you know the big banks on Wall Street so
many of the smaller regional banks in
this country he had a complete power
over these institutions he could have
done whatever he wanted with them he had
seats on their board for pete's sake you
know he can't his votes within the banks
or he did at the time it's all gone now
but he could have fired the management
as he did with General Motors he could
have you know forced them to divest lots
of their parts of their operation he
could have shut certain banks down put
them into receivership all of these
things were totally within his power and
he chose not to do them and that's the
critical thing when you look at the
Obama administration and by the way I
confess to being guilty on this I want
to believe the best about Barack Obama
as a man that I admired enormous ly at
one time and then I admire still I saw
him at the Democratic convention and
every time he speaks I'm just like
I'm blown away by this guy I think he's
the greatest okay at the same time we do
everything in our sort of critical power
to let him off the hook for what he did
as president and I don't think that's
responsible I don't think that's that's
right you know that's responsible yeah
if we're going to be critics if we're
going to write about politics we have to
take ideas seriously we have to take
history seriously and we have to take
what what the president does and says
seriously and I think that the only
thing that you can conclude what you
have to conclude looking at the Obama
administration is that he did what he
did not because his hands were forced by
this you know power or that power this
inability or that inability but because
he chose to do things the way he did
well I think that that gets to and and
and we I'd had a couple other things I
wanted to broach and we do have limited
time left
I think this oh I'm sorry I talk way too
much I apologize for that this area's I
sort of wanted to get to which is in in
reading your book I get the more general
sense that your critique of the
Democratic Party is at least partially
based in the reality that the Democratic
Party while more to the left than the
Republican Party in the u.s. is still
fundamentally a pro-capitalist party it
is that underlying some of the critique
that you're you're outlining well yes of
course but it's not just that they're
pro-capitalist I mean everyone is that
you know it's that they're Pro a certain
kind of capitalism okay so let's never
forget when we talk about the kind of
whatever you want to call it
turbocharged capitalism or neoliberalism
or basically the deregulated modern free
trade era that we're living in that you
know we like to go back and blame it on
Ronald Reagan and that is I think fair
Ronald Reagan is really and Margaret
Thatcher is really where this modern era
of ours begins but the man who put this
agenda into effect more than anybody any
other president more than any other
figure is Bill Clinton a Democrat okay
this is the man who you know President
Reagan tried to overturn glass-steagall
you know he chipped away at it but it's
Bill Clinton that got the job done if
you look at Bill Clinton's presidency
all of these deregulations
the you know the deregulation of the
banking industry that's Clinton that did
that not Reagan and not Bush you know
this is Clinton that achieved those
things that his his staffers would boast
about that and it wasn't just one thing
it wasn't just overturning
glass-steagall there's a whole series of
bank D regulations while Clinton was
president the free trade deals
Republicans yes those are that NAFTA was
their idea it was a Republican idea but
it took a Democrat to get that passed it
was Bill Clinton that got that through
Congress and that was Bill Clinton then
who proposed you know all of the free
trade deals after that and then you look
at chipping away at the welfare state
Reagan tried but he couldn't get very
far
it was Clinton that did away with the
welfare system in this country AFDC that
was you know a New Deal program that was
Clinton that did away with that not
Reagan and in some ways it's only
possible for a Democrat to do these
things but if you when you talk about
the grand sweep of neoliberalism in this
country he is the central figure we have
to acknowledge that among ourselves and
the question becomes why why did
Democrats you know why did the party of
Franklin Roosevelt why are they so keen
to sign on you know sign on to this
agenda and that's the larger question
that I that I tried to answer and listen
liberal going back to the 1960s and
1970s when they started to embrace this
ideology well the book is absolutely
fascinating it is listen liberal it's a
book that both has been talked about
very positively but also negatively by
self-described progressives in my
audience because it does bring up a
number of different very interesting and
controversial issues we've been speaking
with the book's author Thomas Frank and
I encourage you to check out the book
thank you so much for talking to me
today the pleasure is all mine